six years ago today tropical storm irene
caused catastrophic flooding in vermont
irene dumped up to 11 inches of rain on
parts of the state flooding swept away
the homes the roads and the bridges it
cut off some communities for days the
storm caused more than 730 million
dollars in damage and it was vermont's
most devastating natural disaster since
1927. independent vermont senator bernie
sanders fought for legislation to fund
emergency relief in the aftermath of the
storm and this morning the former
presidential candidate is out with a new
book it's called bernie sanders guide to
political revolution dedicated really to
the young adult reader in your house
senator sanders we welcome you back to
this table it's studio 57.
let's start with irene before we get to
the book because are you having a sense
of deja vu when you see what's happening
in texas and how hard you had to fight
to get funds what do you think we went
through that in 2011 i think people
don't appreciate unless you're there
talking to the folks who are impacted
what it means to lose a home that you
lived in your whole life that was there
the day before how are you going to
rebuild it are you going to rebuild it
where do you go
how much resistance did you get senator
we have to fight very hard the vermont
delegation fought very hard for federal
funding gail
it seems to me that at this particular
moment in american history if there is
any silver lining in the terrible
suffering that's going on in houston
it's to remember that we are one country
yeah and i am sure that in houston
whether you're black or you're white or
you're latino or native american or
asian-american people are coming
together to help each other all over the
country people are standing up with the
people in texas who are in trouble we
are one nation and we have got to stop
the type of divisions that trump and
others are bringing about trying to
divide us up we are one people we're
going to stand with the people of texas
today so will the funding that they need
will it get there right away i mean the
senators from texas weren't exactly
forth uh coming when it came to the
money for super fast both voted against
hurricane sandy and we have got to end
that stuff the people i i quite sure i
speak for the people of vermont saying
we are going to stand with the people of
texas and the lesson to be learned is
when people in any part of the country
are in trouble as one nation we stand
together you're saying now is not the
time we're tit for tat no it is not so
you are a yes vote well you got to see
the bill it has to be a good bill
you know and it has to be and this is
tough stuff i mean how do you document
exactly the kind of laws and roads and
bridges and infrastructure
but clearly i am sympathetic uh to
supporting the senator cruz said there
was a lot of pork in the sandy funding
was that true no
no period look it is hard i mean you put
yourself in the place of a governor and
you're preparing the documentation as to
the damage done may there be some
mistakes but generally speaking i think
the effort was sincere and honest we
don't want pork but when you're talking
about bridges and roads and homes and
people suffering
we've got to stand with them so what are
the lessons they could learn from what
you went through to make sure that the
people of texas get exactly what they
need in an efficient manner well it has
to be done efficiently it has to be done
rapidly a lot of that responsibility is
going to rest with the people the
officials in houston in the state of
texas and right now right now the
immediate task is to make sure that we
save lives that we protect people that
there's emergency shelters the day after
we figure out how we rebuild houston
president trump is heading there today
is that a good idea
well yeah i don't know but uh you know
clearly i think
well there's one school of stock they're
still in the middle of it uh i mean i
mean i think generally speaking the task
right now is for uh the officials to do
everything they can to protect the
people of houston is it too soon for a
presidential visit
too soon for the president to be there
probably it is but uh
let's not get into that the focus right
now has got to be on doing everything
that we can uh to address the terrible
terrible pain that is taking place in
that city i want to ask you about this
book um that you've written here
political revolution a guide to it a lot
of the things we heard you say in the
campaign trail and you talk about in
here the need to rebuild infrastructure
your concern about some trade policies
the need to lower the cost of
prescription drugs these are all things
that actually president trump calls for
as well why do you think that
independents like yourself or democrats
are finding it difficult to work with
the president he constantly complains
that democrats are obstruction because
because he during the campaign said one
set of things and the policies that he's
implementing right now are very
different during the course of the
campaign he said i'm going to stand with
the working people i'm going to take on
the pharmaceutical industry and lower
the outrageously high cost of
prescription drugs that's what he said
that's not what he's doing he said i'm
going to drain the swamp i'm going to
get rid of the powerful special interest
well he has brought more billionaires
into his administration
than any president in the history of
this country he says i'm going to
guarantee health care to everybody well
he supported legislation that would
throw 32 million people off of health
insurance but having said that and by
the way getting back to houston i think
we want to take a look at infrastructure
we want to take a look at climate change
and what that may mean to the future of
this country but bottom line is as a
nation we have got to stand together we
cannot allow the divisions that are
taking place
uh every single day led by the president
whether you're black or white a latino
we are one nation let's work together
well we're seeing that play out in
houston because when you're getting
rescued you don't care what color the
person absolutely i love that i love the
tone of the book it's it's it's geared
towards young adults not children as the
senators people pointed out in the green
room i said this is great for kids they
go nope young adults but you say the
young adults this generation is the
smartest least prejudiced and most
idealistic and gail that is exactly what
i believe that's what i've seen all over
this country look what this book is
about is saying that we have a real
crisis in american democracy and what
does that mean it means that we have the
lowest voter turnout of almost any major
country on earth it means that we're
seeing as a result of this disastrous
citizens united supreme court decision
billionaires able to buy elections spend
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars supporting candidates who
represent the wealthy and the powerful
what's the antidote to that the antidote
is to bring people into the political
process run for school board run for
city council run for state legislature
but why are you optimistic about this
generation and what age group are you
talking about well from you know 16 on
up i have seen these people yes and it
is
they voted for you the 18 and older
groups well many of them did
but this is a generation that is beyond
in many respects racism sexism
homophobia xenophobia i have seen these
young people stand together talk about
climate change they need to transform
our energy system to take on the
oligarchy that controls our country it
is a beautiful generation of young
people and what we want to do is see
them get involved in the political
process and this book provides the tools
to do that real quick before we let you
go that sounds suspiciously like
everything you said on the campaign
trail you running again well it's a
little bit
a little bit early to talk about that
let's focus on the issues impacting the
american people we'll take that as a yes
it's never too early
and we'll stay in touch senator thank
you very much thank you